good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast brought to you by
betterhelp it doesn't matter who you are
or what you have life can be pretty damn
hard and without a healthy mind it's
even harder check out online therapy
with betterhelp.com toast and be on your
way to a little more ease welcome back
to the show happy hump day
starting the week with a hump day the
work week for us with a hump day it's an
amazing feeling it rarely happens it
rarely happens and also it really it's
the last episode we did was on friday
where we were literally scraping the
bottom of the barrel for something
somewhat interesting to discuss
little did we know all we had to do was
take off two days monday and tuesday for
labor day in rosh hashanah to come on
wednesday with the juiciest show we've
had in a while yeah there's so much to
talk about and it's really exciting to
have things in which to talk about and
some really like exciting news that i
feel personally invested in yeah there's
a lot going on first layers obviously
all the celebrity news that happened in
the last three days like literally all
last night just so [ __ ] crazy
two
i watched the most television i've ever
watched in my life over the holiday and
over the weekend because i didn't do
anything over the weekend and i cannot
wait to discuss things we both watched
things i just watched and the tv recap
is [ __ ] quaking the tv recap is
quaking and i just have three words
the demilio show the [ __ ]
millio show
and by the way just programming like we
don't have time for dear toasters today
like we have so much because your
toasters is on tuesday we're not gonna
skip it this week
no no we're just it's gonna be just on a
slower day no but it's like when we do
when we miss a tv recap that was
supposed to be like we don't then recap
it the next day like it just it's on its
day you mean you're gonna wait till next
tuesday for your toasters yeah i do i
don't know if the toasters would be too
pleased to hear about this i think that
it's in line with our stance
on other issues
we'll see we'll talk about it after at
our strategizing meeting
and then third where was i celebrity
news tv i'm excited to talk about and
you have something to talk to me about
you said
i do is that the third thing no but
thank you for reminding me the third
thing is that we also were a part of all
the drama last night because we dropped
a patreon episode with the biggest
[ __ ] bomb
in our family's legacy and that's saying
a lot okay like we were saying last
night like this is the craziest episode
i think we'll ever record and i
personally like was not being click bait
exaggerating i was not lying like when i
think about like the news that we could
share like this is one of the craziest
things that we've shared because if you
know us as a family which most of you do
like it's
wild it's wild so the new podcast is up
we dropped it last night it's on our
patreon patreon is our subscription
service you guys know 7.99 a month gets
you five extra episodes and it gets you
early access to the juiciest drops like
last night we were in the studio with
the third person who dropped a truth
bomb and that's all i'll say yeah
now the thing i wanted to talk to you
about great so you recommended me this
book
and
okay no let me finish i just want to let
everyone know it's the book i've been
saying that's a sweet rom-com that's
extremely porny it is not a rom-com it
is literally erotica okay let me just
say that okay and so you kept calling me
yesterday like
did you read more did you read more and
i was very involved in this tv show
which i'll talk about in the tv recap so
i didn't read more okay and i could not
sleep last night just because i've had
five days off i've been like sleeping
till noon so i was like really off ben
is snoring away and i'm like you know
what i could read
and
i read two chapters i'm about like maybe
almost 70 percent of the way through
what's the book called again it happened
one summer by tessa bailey everyone
every time i say it's the raunchy porn
book everyone's like wait what was it
again it is pornography like i was shook
that you read this book and i was
wondering why like you were calling me
so much like asking if i read the book
like who [ __ ] cares and then i
finished i think it's chapter 19. um
and i was
cackling in my bed understanding why you
were calling me asking if i read the
book because spoiler alert she puts her
finger up her boyfriend's butt is that
what you were referring to i wasn't
waiting for anything in particular
i just wanted to like one when i
recommend the book to someone like i'd
like to know how it's going i knew that
you were reading a lot this weekend yeah
so i just wanted to know if like things
were in line with you know how i said
they would be so you weren't waiting for
me to see the finger in the bum no like
to me there was like so much you know
stuff happening in every scene
that not one thing not one stuff like
stuck out stood out not one finger no
one finger okay because like i finished
the chapter and i was cackling because
it was all coming together like that's
probably why you were calling me that's
a [ __ ] crazy thing to happen in the
book like it's an insane [ __ ] book
and by the way i like it i can't believe
you read it and liked it okay so i read
it because sinich almost chose it for
the redheads thank the lord that she
didn't yes that you guys couldn't really
have like an intellectually stimulating
conversation no
um
and i was surprised by how much i liked
it considering like it's so poorly it's
so ia and i thought i thought i think
that the love story is like really there
i think so too it gives me this like the
vibe of like people like joke about
twilight but like we really know like
twilight is a true love story right and
they are both some of the most talented
actors in the business and people are
like oh twilight like i agree with you
it's like a silly book but the love
between brendan spoiler alert
and piper is real right so that's why i
recommend it to everyone because i think
it's a nice book but it's also like
embarrassing on my part i was going to
say don't you feel weird recommended i
do i feel extremely hard that's why i
can't say like it happened one summer by
testability without being like it is
extremely raunchy and important you're
not selling it it's erotica like period
no but here's the thing they probably
can't sell it in bookstores i think we
were talking about it with snitch at
rosh hashanah and i need her to read it
because all the books that she reads are
raunch porn
and i want to know if this book is more
than usual or is it just another book in
the life of smith well i feel like i
read a good amount of erotica because i
read so much colleen hoover and like she
really
it puts so much unnecessary porn in her
books and i could tell you definitively
that this book is the most erratic i
think i i've never read 50 shades but i
think it's up there
i agree if not i agree but snitch reads
like
all these books she read 50 shades is
this just another day in the life for
snitch so also for the toasters and
readers out there please read this book
and let us know what you think where
does it rank on the porn scale so like
for you it's a 10. it's the corniest
book you've ever read yes
i would think for me too i have to like
think back to things that i've read but
i would think for me too yes yeah like
you know it's bad well not bad but like
it's high on the porn list when the
author refers to a woman's vagina as her
sex
oh well also the p word oh by the way
oh we talked about that at russia and
not at the on the
podcast
this book said the p word
[ __ ]
and i was so shook by the way when i was
i read two chapters last night said it
again might have even said it three
times yeah no she the author comes out
big and bold yeah with the word [ __ ]
it's
it's shocking to see it on your kindle
you know
you can click on it
so i spent a lot of the weekend watching
tv i'm also almost through that book i
really like it like it's very sweet i'm
not trying to rush through it it's just
shocking like it's the level of porn
like it's just a lot for like the book
the content of the book but i want to
know from other readers who read mostly
why a which is also synonymous with
erotica
what do you think it happened one summer
by tessa bailey and it's also just a
good book it is it's cute um and then
other things we're gonna dive into the
tv recap but we both watched the demilio
show last night i finished click bait
which was like everyone's obsessed with
and i have a lot of thoughts and i don't
know if you'd like it but it was pretty
good
i also watched um only murders in the
building okay
and i watched i was spent a lot of time
on who i watched some of nine perfect
strangers and i just i have a lot of
thoughts on everything especially the
demilio show i know that you and i are
really on the same page about that so
that will be in our tv recap but before
that like there's so much to do there's
so much to do and i watched cinderella
oh yes
so i'll let everyone know what i thought
about it
give us a sneak peek i watched shrek 4 i
thought it was incredibly dark
and like i don't know what the campers
are going to be doing
i've never seen trek four because in the
storyline the storyline didn't even ring
a bell
um and it was just a lot of like
it was it was hard there was like an
ogre revolution like it's insane and
ogarucian yeah like it was crazy trek
four is like the
personification of like too much of a
good thing yeah but they also like did a
pretty good job but it was just like too
dark like rumpelstiltskin like is an
animal
anyways
what else did i watch
emilio's
cinderella i think that's it if anything
else comes to me i'll let you know i
finished my book empty mansions took me
forever i wouldn't really recommend
could have been an article this is a
meeting that could have been an email a
book that could have been an article
yeah um okay i feel like we should just
dive in because it's like killing me not
to talk about certain things
without further without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
before we dive in i have a very funny do
story
last night was the second night of the
first night after erev of rosh hashanah
and me and ben had um the russia shed a
meal with his family and you know theo
just like was running amuck like living
his life and then we get home
and we're laying in bed and i'm like
smelling something
and i'm like
do you smell
matzo ball soup
and ben's like yeah i do and we're like
sniffing around like where's the soup
and literally theo's ears sopping wet
it smelled like dill you know the smell
of like mozzarella i have no idea how it
got in there but like no one was really
paying attention to him when we were at
dinner so he must have just like run
into the kitchen maybe hopped on the
counter and like drink some soup good
for him he just wanted to celebrate yeah
he's such a good jewish boy and like of
everything he could have snagged
the soup
good for the soul so sweet that's
probably still small i didn't watch it
that's a beautiful story it was a
stunning moment okay of yiddish height
and spirituality and ruach in our family
yes and so now without further ado like
we won't dilly dally any longer before
we let you know that pregnant kylie
jenner is showing off her baby bump for
the first time in a new video posted to
her instagram confirming the rumors are
true uh deleted my twitter and that
kylie is pregnant kylie is pregnant
part two no this isn't surprising just
because like there have been all these
series and if you're like in the know
and you watch tick tock like you knew
that she probably might have been
pregnant um
i'm glad that she was able to
tell on her own terms i do feel like all
these conspiracy theories like probably
pushed up her announcement dates
slightly i do feel sad like i don't know
i just like hate that we live in this
world like where people just can't
announce their own pregnancy but then
you know i did you know fall down in a
small rabbit hole on tick-tock this
morning like people thinking kylie's
already given birth
um because in one of the videos stormy
is wearing like
uh christmas pajamas so like if the
timeline were to add up i don't [ __ ]
know i just see stormy being like sort
of chaotic about when she celebrates her
holidays and like kylie of course would
never do that but she would allow stormy
too because she wants stormy to be happy
i don't think that's true because like
for a few months especially in the
beginning of the year like kylie was
like always with her friends
1942
going to the beach like crazy stuff
that's true so i think i saw one
thing like a comment or something that
said based on her manicures in the
videos and like
timing that she's probably due in
december
that'd be crazy that'd be crazy and i
just want to say like
it means something to me to be pregnant
at the same time as kylie of course like
it's what are you a monster i don't know
like i don't know if people would like
think that these things matter
it matters i am just like over the moon
do you feel even better about your
decision to get knocked up now a hundred
percent and just like what a great
fabulous pregnancy buddy and so i guess
she would be like two months ahead of me
i'm hoping maybe she's like january and
she's just like um
maybe that tick tockers aren't right
maybe those like belly pictures were
from yesterday and that's why she was
waiting to post this video until she had
like more belly pics and the video was
fabulous by the way like it was really
sweet to the point yes exactly so i just
like it's just going to be such a fun
journey and i was the one who i did say
that i thought that with this pregnancy
kylie would give would be giving us
pregnant kylie you did say that so i'm
excited to see that and then also like
the postpartum journey i'm excited to
like hopefully line up with her and like
see where she's at and all these things
no it's stunning and the rumors are that
she's having a boy just because she's
been using like blue heart emojis on
stuff which is like pretty i don't know
if she would be that obviously pretty
thin yeah um but then that's also
exciting for me totally like maybe two
boys our boys could be friends maybe
your boys could be boys and they would
say we them boys
what we making noises that's what the
boys would say as they came out of your
vagina out of your out of your sex
out of here
no
it's good to have goals in life and
that's one no it's really fabulous news
like i love you know what i love it's
like there's so many rumors about like
kylie travis like travis has a side
[ __ ] like maybe it's true but like they
always present a united front and i just
like love that for them yeah no i really
do too and
i'm so happy i'm happy for kylie me too
and i loved the kris jenner um sonogram
moment i know but it's also crazy to me
that kylie waited till her first
sonogram which is usually around like
seven eight weeks in order to share with
chris it did feel like
they were really surprised
you think like when she
had was in the beginning of the video
had the pregnancy test and her and
travis were like what like i got the
vibe that it was like a shock like it
wasn't planned
oh
that's just me i don't know maybe
because i've been reading like some of
the rumors where it's like they've been
trying and you know she wants another
baby like i just assumed that they were
trying
it's possible but
so i just i loved it all and all the
like sisters are so excited for her
yes it's so cute like it's very very
sweet and i love that she's like out and
about now you know like who knows the
possibilities for what we can get from
kylie in the next couple months are
endless and you know i'm really feeling
creatively like stymied in terms of
pregnancy maternity wear maternity wear
especially at this stage where it's like
my clothes like don't really fit
like yeah my usual clothes but like when
i look at maternity websites it's for
like really big bellies so i'm just kind
of in this in-between phase leggings
leggings yeah um so i'm looking too
forward to seeing like what kylie brings
to the table maybe some inspo because
like you should do kylie
maturity i know um now that i've been
like looking for maternity clothes and
there are some good options like asus
has maternity just placed in order oh
good there's hatch that they reach out
to me they're gonna send me some tings
fabulous um there's some cool maternity
wear but like of course it's like
there's a gap in the market no there is
no but there is like for real yeah but
then i'm sure like then you give birth
and you forget about the gap and you
move on until of course till the next
time of course yeah but not everyone
like is pregnant and has to look their
best on a tea on a tv show uh on a tv
show yeah on a world-renowned peabody
award-winning show agreed not everybody
so i'm just gonna keep going with the
things that stretch and then i'll let
you guys know by the way that's my
department like if you want to go
shopping just let me know i was really
like close to looking in zack's closet
today no but it's like i'm not that big
like that would be really like
unnecessary no that would just be like
it would actually be concerning if you
were at that stage when you're only like
three months or four months yeah but i
have been wearing some of his like um
bottoms to bed because
the waistband starts to get like a
little tight oh by the way i sleep in
beds on these like almost every night
clean cool clean
i assumed so happy for kylie like in the
whole jenner family
the webster family like i don't know how
stormy's gonna take you know
being a big sister no longer center of
attention having to share the stage but
it's a part of growing up maybe stormy
was just putting on an act in the video
but she did look really excited yeah of
course it's all exciting until like
something comes and takes like literally
all the attention away from you yeah i
don't know i feel like stormy is ready
to share she must have so much attention
and so much toys yeah and that can
be be good and bad it but there's
nothing like a friend there's nothing
like a sister or a brother
yeah
are you ready for our next story which
is a little more pregnancy news olivia
munn is pregnant with john mullaney's
baby john mulaney and olivia munn are
excited
a baby the stand-up comedian confirmed
the actress's pregnancy news tuesday on
late night with seth meyers while
discussing his eventful year and their
whirlwind whirlwind relationship
chris said crickets
um
we're having a baby together i was
nervous when i was about to say the news
i'm gonna be a dad
obviously i think it's great welcoming a
child into the world i don't want to say
anything negative about his pregnancy a
lot of factors at play here he announced
his divorce four months ago
now of course we don't know everything
maybe they've been unhappy for four
years like not judging the timeline but
i am judging this whole situation i'm
sorry like it's just too weird
yeah and a picture emerged of her a few
days ago yes um looking pregnant looking
pregnant so i guess that maybe is what
prompted them to
announce the pregnancy yeah i also and i
just want to say i'm four months
pregnant
and she looks more pregnant than me well
so i do think it's weird that he went on
a tv show and gave a timeline of his
like that's really personal like sharing
the pregnancy update with us is already
like a wonderful thing but
it just felt really personal to him
giving the timeline the breakdown like
sort of like we didn't do anything wrong
and i was like well i didn't think you
did but now i do yeah he said i went to
rehab in september 2020 i got out in
october i move out of my home for my
ex-wife i host snl on halloween i
relapse on drugs then i continued using
drugs i went to rehab again this time
for two months i got out in february i
lived in sober living for another month
and a half then in the spring i went to
la and met and started to date a
wonderful woman named olivia so it's
just weird like maybe the timeline adds
up but like it's just yeah why do we why
do we know that maybe in reality he
separated from his wife in fall of 2020
and now you know
a year later
they're expecting right but from the
people's pov they announced their
divorce four months ago
no you know what's so weird about the
world is like you maybe a year ago you
couldn't tell me that like people would
turn on john mullaney like he is adored
like he is the biggest are people turn i
haven't read i think people feel very
defensive of his ex-wife anna like she
was a pee job like they were such a
great couple so he also like always
maintained that he didn't want children
oh is that true yeah he was on comedians
and cars getting coffee like and comedy
is more personal than food and he said
that he didn't want kids nothing like
never but you know they're just like
wasn't in their plan yeah and they're
happy with you know where they're at and
oh my god that that's like another like
[ __ ] up layer
no the story is so weird and like it's
really i know this is terrible this is
just my opinion and i don't want to send
anything to anyone but like this whole
story line makes me hate these two
people so much and like just the fact
that like we now live in a world where
john mulaney is like at the center of
like some weird ethical scandal is just
not what i expected because he's like
known as like the p john comedian like
everyone loved him and they loved him
and his wife and like i just didn't
think this is how like
life was going to turn out for john
mullaney and now that it has like i
personally just need to like digest that
okay
take your time i'm really like not that
familiar with him so me neither like not
at all me this like
i'm more i know olivia munn more yeah no
this is just like
it's too much it's a lot but ultimately
happy news for the happy couple
mazel tov i just don't
and like the announcement was really
awkward like maybe there's no one in
seth meyer's
studio i don't know if he has a studio
audience but there's like four people
clapping and it was just like crickets
yeah
it's too weird like i don't even know
how to feel but i'm just feeling not
good
i'm i'm feeling like i'm curious how
other people feel like people who
actually like and like know and respect
his comedy like i really don't know
anything about him i've never been a fan
but i don't know just like after
watching the demilio show like i don't
want to say anything negative about
anyone ever again by the way because you
just never [ __ ] know totally like
before i watched emilio's show i would
have said if i thought about charlie and
dixie that they must be like
the happiest girls in the world because
look at the love look at their life
and you just never know
you know
but we'll get to that in the tv recap we
always do are you ready for our next
story yeah britney spears's father asks
the judge to end her conservatorship so
much news in a surprise move britney
spears his father asked a judge on
tuesday to enter conservatorship which
would allow the singer unfettered
control over her life her finances and
her health care decisions for the first
time in 13 years jamie spears filed a
petition with probate judge brenda penny
saying that recent events have shown
that she should get that chance to
control her own affairs quote
has told this court that she wants
control of her life back without the
safety rails of a conservatorship she
wants to be able to make decisions
regarding her own medical care deciding
when where and how often to get therapy
she wants to control the money she has
made from her career and spend it
without supervision or oversight crazy
she wants to be able to get married and
have a baby if she so chooses in short
she wants to live her life as she
chooses without the constraints of a
conservator or court proceeding
so i just don't feel like his intentions
here are pure i feel like he's not doing
this because he cares about brittany
like he cannot take being the most hated
man in america now and like the
consequences of his actions are catching
up with him so he's doing this i think
in an attempt to like appease the public
to get people off his ass not really
because he cares about brady but at the
end of the day the result would be the
same and i'm obviously thrilled about it
okay i have a few more thoughts about
this because
i agree there's there's he's not just
like a benign sort of guy like oh okay
oh you didn't like it 13 years let me
fix it yeah oh sorry oops okay but i
think and i remember when all like the
trial was happening and brittany was
speaking like there are a lot of people
who believe that britney like might we
don't know what's going on with brittany
people believe that she might need a
conservative
but i think the conservatorship that
she's been under has been insanely
abusive and controlling and i think
there was a way for what she wanted was
a different conservator and more freedom
you know like the way she was living and
working and and her allowance like
in her
iud it's just like nuts nuts so i feel
like
i feel like she there's a chance that
she needs a conservator again we don't
know like the medical diagnosis
that or you know where she's at and so
by him like say like just taking it away
completely it's like he wants to see her
like
he wants to show everyone you know by
the way the way that thing was worded
was definitely patronizing like all
right she doesn't want anyone to look
after her medical care like no one will
look yeah you know i feel what you're
saying like it
it doesn't seem like this is like an
actual like white flag surrender it's
like all right fine you don't want my
help don't take it yeah it sounded very
bitter yeah and also i just i can't
really believe after like 13 years of
her you know privately probably telling
him like please stop yeah and now
publicly that all of a sudden he's he
got a change of heart yeah so i do think
there's something nefarious here going
on he's trying like a different route
color us skeptical i am skeptical um but
ultimately you know
i still think if it's
if it's between being conserved with
jamie or no conservatorship obviously
yeah
no it's just like a crazy whirlwind i
don't know if this petition he submitted
will actually get it done though because
it seems like everyone in this case the
judges like everyone is somehow
being bribed or is is involved so like
no justice ever gets served it's like
we're like running in circles yeah so
maybe this is like jamie like look i'm a
hero oh but the judge didn't allow it i
have to stay yeah so i just don't buy
any like until britney is free like i
won't buy anything i agree
i'm so skeptical and we keep getting
these updates that like seem like good
updates or seem like big news and he's
stepping down and then it's like wait
nobody's not did anyone actually read
the report like right there's so much
fake [ __ ] news you're totally right
so until like she's on her instagram on
ig live like saying everything she wants
to say driving in her car
with a you know with a handheld
hands-free hands-free device i won't
believe it yeah
but we are hopeful yes let's go oh yes
oh yes cautiously optimistic
okay
now some next big news just they keep
coming they keep we're five for five
like we don't have time for [ __ ]
stories today we are five or five scott
disick and amelia hamlin breakup
the 20-year-old model and the
38-year-old reality star have broken up
after less than a year of dating page
six has confirmed a source told us
weekly on tuesday that amelia was the
one who ended things with scott quote
they're both taking it in stride i
actually believe that reminder the
breakup news comes just a week after the
talentless designers private messages
about that sounds funny yeah about x
kourtney kardashian were made public
obviously scott messaging eunice yo is
this chick okay
um definitely like we said
pissed off would piss off
amelia's girlfriend honestly like
this whole i have so many thoughts about
this whole relationship and lisa and
everything
but if it is if this is how it played
out like amelia felt like hella
disrespected by all this i actually have
a lot of respect for amelia because the
way that it looks is like
of course like amelia will never break
up with scott like it's the most
relevant famous person she'll ever date
like her whole family like pretends not
to be excited but they are like so if
she did actually break up with him like
out of respect for herself like you
can't be going around like embarrassing
me like i have a lot of respect for that
i just have to say i don't know if
that's how it played out that is how
this article made it seem but you really
never know but i will respect that
because that is an admirable thing to do
to have self-respect in a relationship
like that right we had assumed last week
it was just another day in the district
household right like that wouldn't
bother her like like in a relationship
like that i don't like it go to your
room yeah no
and in those types of relationships like
you don't really get to be mad like yeah
it's yes it is what it is yeah or you
can go yeah you don't like it leave and
so
she left and so that does give me like a
little bit of like a
look at look at amelia respect but now
now we have to talk about lisa arena and
her like social media antics in the last
few days like she posted a picture of
harry styles because like on real
housewives of beverly hills when asked
about scott she pretends to be upset and
she's like why couldn't she have just
dated harry styles like
all right get in line lisa first of all
second of all um
she posted the picture of
of harry leading people to think that
like maybe they were
not doing well scott and amelia and then
this whole news came out and she
responded to someone's
comment just like confirming that like
you know she was just like putting
herself in the middle of it and like
honestly now that the relationship's
over it's so easy for like lisa to be
like oh well i didn't like this i didn't
approve but like where were you right
where were you when your 19 year old
daughter was dating almost a 40 year old
man yeah like
it's easy to be the hero now yeah
but
where were you like pretending beverly
hills like oh
dis like stop stop yeah we're not buying
it no we're not but
that's that on that i guess i'm so
thrilled to no longer have to not talk
to avoid go out of my way talking about
them hopefully he engages in an
age-appropriate relationship good luck
hopefully she does as well
i don't think so
you don't think so from either of them
no i'm sure emily will find someone her
age but
scott yeah it's a pattern now yeah and
that's where
it makes it difficult for me it's like a
fan of his like to really respect
anything he does big time big time
are you ready for
the final story for what
the final story
[Music]
we're cool for the summer
[Music]
another
we're cool for the summer
we are cool for the summer okay we're
cool for the summer and now we're ready
for the fifth and final story which is
the full dancing with the stars season
30 cast
and it's really a good one it is the
cast of
the new season of dancing with the stars
includes the talk co-host amanda cloots
which we announced last week and by the
way she was a rock hat yeah she was a
dancer she was a rocket not just a
dancer like the dance the creme de la
creme that means cream of dancers
still like that in front of theo he's
the cream of the cream of dancers
he's a rockettes getting out there
shaking that thing no but i just want to
like i don't want to move on to the next
one yet until we like talk about how
unfair this is no i know like love him
at the clutes live for everything
support but
this is up there with heather morrison
like a former rocket next charlie
demilia was going to be on dancing in
the stars she should be she's an amazing
dancer yeah and she's like trained no
this is this is insane like
it's worse than like suny lee and when
you know someone biles was on like it's
worse
then we also have beverly hills 90210's
brian austin green
oh sharna and brian like literally
couldn't carolize loserville population
two moving on bling empire is christine
chu
no way yeah oh that's good yeah that is
good she's a perfect type of person i
bet she's a terrible dancer like but
she'll learn and get better like that's
what it's supposed to be and then
perhaps the most exciting casting
announcement peloton instructor cody
rigsby yes i saw that this morning he is
going to bring everything he has claudia
i'm so excited for you to watch because
you're going to love him so much like
he's going to kill it i know what i know
his vibe like i see him all over tik tok
and he obviously has rhythm because
of his classes and they're so like with
the music but like he's not a
dancer so he's actually the perfect
casting yep and i'm so excited to see
his like personality come through his
song choices like he also has just like
creative vision and i think and he's
like obsessed with pop culture and like
so many celebrities and musicians he's
like the perfect casting i think it was
amazing and like he's in the homes of
millions of americans like he has a deep
wide reach like i do think people will
vote for him like he's not so obvious
like matt james but he is like really
he's like
a part of people's everyday lives yes
and is he going to be doing his peloton
no he's going to take some time off i
don't know
if he'll do a class like yeah he's going
to train and stay in shape yeah
and then he could like tell everyone to
vote for him no literally like
he should still do the classes he should
i mean there's definitely peloton
studios in l.a for sure um and also it's
just like exciting to see like peloton
instructors who for the last almost two
years have become such a big part of
everybody's lives like seeing them
become traditional famous people no it's
fabulous yes
former nba player iman shumpert oh he
has a new reality show yes so i'm sure
like he's you know promoting yeah
country star jimmy allen
oh that's good that is good it's
surprising though because he's like
really taking off yeah so now he's gonna
do that they always gotta throw a
country star in there yeah
youtube superstar jojo siwa we knew
fabulous i feel like she's been waiting
around for like months for this yeah
real housewives of atlanta's kenya more
no way
yes we said that last week and that was
your reaction last week i feel like
she's not gonna like it no i don't she
really likes to be in control of things
i don't think she's gonna like it at all
i feel like she's gonna like pull elysee
vanderpump and like fake break her ankle
or something i yeah i agree with you
cobra kai's martin cove
the bachelor's matt james yes there's
always someone from the bachelor um i
did see a video of matt dancing because
he made a tick tock with suny lee i
don't know why i just assumed like he
was a good dancer when he literally has
no rhythm he was like atrocious i saw
him make a tick tock with tyler c the
one with their shirts off and i thought
it was good i remember that one
i thought it was good spice girls mel c
that's good that's exciting wait mel c
sporty
melcy
sporty oh wow
mel b is like popping she's on america's
got talent but mel c like i have not
heard from her since her iconic solo
song
how does it go
she released a solo song that i think is
one of the best songs ever written whoa
and just give me one second it's worth
it's worth mel
which one c
just give me a second melanie c
oh i turn to you that's her like a
flower leaning towards the sun
i turn to you
cause you're the only one
who can turn me around
when i'm upside down down
i turn to you
[Music]
so good right so good i didn't realize
that was her then the office's melora
hardin
they don't watch office oh by the way
yes that is jacqueline
from the bowl type from the bold type
wow love that first she's also the
principal from 17 again
okay and she goes out sure with the guy
yeah
so good i love her yeah okay i am
excited i'm so glad she found you know a
new project after the bowl type yeah uh
wwe's mike the miz
oh mr mrs miz miz and the miss that
atrocious reality show like eastern no
it's miz and misses oh okay okay i think
i've never seen it me neither the
commercials are enough to make me know
it's literally the worst show on
television okay olivia jade and suny lee
okay just run through like the two most
interesting we spoke about them last
week i cannot believe the olivia jade
rumor was true like i hope
that she has fun
i think that
enough time has passed i hope that
people don't like make fun of her like
she's just a person
um
and i'll be rooting for her like a
hundred percent yeah who do you think's
gonna win
well it's tough because you have to be
really popular but you also have to be
good because at some point your
popularity can only take you so far so
like that's my concern with like matt
james
you know i don't think he's a very good
dancer
but i think of course his fan base will
take him you know halfway there yeah
i think that jojo can make it really far
because she's very good and very popular
you have to true i like i don't know
what amanda klutz is like following it's
like does she have like you know she's
mature women who are not gonna be
staying up all night you know calling a
million times but her skill could get
her very far right right so i don't know
jojo siwa is definitely a front runner
suny lee is definitely a front runner
yeah i don't know what olivia j dance i
feel like melora harden like could be
someone who's just like people
definitely like want to root for yeah
yeah that's like that other season that
we watch where the woman from the office
is just alcoholic who works in like
accounting yeah she made it really far
even though like she doesn't have like a
gaggle of millions of followers who are
like waiting up like texting you know
using three different phones to send
their votes in yeah so it'll be actually
a very interesting season my only
problem with becoming a fan of dancing
with the stars which i literally became
last year is
it's such long episodes it's similar to
the bachelor like they have a million
commercial breaks they have useless like
packages like of people dancing through
la like just show us the dancing and
give us the score and move on yeah yeah
they waste so much time they can't help
themselves they can't it's like an abc
trademark okay well it premieres monday
september 20th if you want to watch and
speaking of tv we must get into the tv
recap let me open my list but let's
definitely start off with the emilio
show they have a reality show on hulu if
you haven't watched it i really do
suggest it it's much different than i
thought it was going to be yes um and i
think that was good and bad because just
from an entertainment perspective i
really liked getting to know the girls
and their business but i do feel like
the whole show every episode was about
the same thing and it's an important
conversation for sure but i'm just
saying from an entertainment perspective
it did get like a little
like repetitive at the end yes i agree
it was really surprising i thought this
family was getting a show and it was
going to be like silly family antics and
like fabulous events like most
family reality shows are and you know
you get a little bit of the real life
and whatever it would mostly be like
them you know doing silly things right
like going to an art class there was
really not that much that was silly
about this show
and i have so many thoughts on the whole
but i will say like i said earlier in
the show when i would think if i ever
thought about charlie and dixie emilio
like before watching the show i would
have assumed that they were so happy the
luckiest girls
like just so excited
and they have ever like to go from like
just being you know a regular
connecticut and then to have this level
of fame that like you know in one year
charlie's on the time 100 list like it's
unprecedented it's the real definition
of like what's that phrase be careful
what you wish for because you just might
get it yeah so i was not prepared to see
and to me when i think of charlie and
dixie like they're so loved she has the
most currently as most followers on tik
tok because people love her so i was so
surprised to see
how much hate they deal with like how it
affects them so
but i also think that they don't have
good systems in place for dealing with
it i completely agree like it was
shocking to see a how much they get and
b how it really bothers them like
they're not just like these larger than
life figures they really are just like
[ __ ] 16 and 19 year old girls who
like if somebody if you were in high
school and somebody came up to and
called you musty like you would cry and
so they cried because they're children
right and it's so crazy when you keep
reminding yourself that charlie is 16
and then you like think back to where
you were at 16 and like if someone was
like capturing my personality on a
reality show and also like her
personality it keeps changing episode
she's evolving she's a teenager and like
she doesn't know who she is yeah and
charlie is so young but like so is dixie
dixie's now like dixie's the older one
so i think like people give her less
grace in that sense but like she's still
[ __ ] 19. she can't even have a sip of
alcohol exactly crazy i was just
thinking like at their birthday party
like charlie at the end i'm like
are they drinking no no i mean i they
don't
seem like that i wasn't getting drinking
vibes from any of the shows yeah but
like the fact that they sit on their
phones all day they wake up roll over
grab their phone and read comments like
is so unhealthy and i would just i would
have just assumed that like
they either some most people who are
that famous don't read comments right
but they got really famous like from the
comments
section from the comment section so okay
they're probably like accustomed to
reading comments but like why like i was
after watching the show i'm like they
should have two phones one for posting
tick tocks and like looking at instagram
and all those things and like one for
texting their friends like they should
not be allowed to be on that tick tock
phone all [ __ ] day and they sit
around with their parents and they're
like reading comments about themselves
like while they're trying to have a
conversation and it's like
the parents should be like get off your
phone like because what they're doing on
there is so harmful yeah honestly like
there's one part of the show that gave
me a pit and i'm i'm not critiquing
anyone's parenting at all but i didn't
because the kids are in unchartered
territory of course and they and they
admittedly they said like we have no
idea what we're doing i just feel like
there's like there's more that they
could be doing to protect their
daughter's mental health like you know
charlie's having a breakdown dixie's
having a breakdown and like they're
filming it and like literally the
filming is the
it's the antithesis of what they need
and you know they told charlie to take a
break they cleared her schedule for a
week and thought that it would fit and
i'm sure she definitely helped like
clearing her schedule for one week like
no no girl needs like a six month break
like
i just feel like her the parents kept
giving me a pit and it's like
they live in this house that like is
paid for by the kids it just feels like
this like kind of really weird
backwards type of dynamic and i just
felt like i wish that
and maybe they do it and we don't see it
i just wish that like the parents had
handled a lot of the things differently
well towards the end the
charlie's changed her schedule she only
works three days a week and it's between
11 and 4 and if you want to work with
her and i think that's much healthier
and it must be really crazy and i almost
wish i know that they would never share
this but like
explain to us how much money you're
making that's worth putting your kids
through this because i'm sure it's so
much money right
and most people would choose like that
and this the truckers for charlie
chuckles for charlie over going home to
connecticut of course like for the
average viewer it's like how could you
be putting your kids through this and
then dad keeps saying like
well if it ever gets too much like we'll
go back home we'll call it quits and
it's like
we have reached that point to me it
looks like it's too much
a hundred percent are so miserable
they're crying every single day multiple
times a day
they can't enjoy like regular things
like meals with their friends or with
their family like
they're broken it's so sad it's so sad
especially considering those are girls
that i would consider have a net
positive life experience on the internet
because they're so well i had no idea
charlie gets so much hate like or that
they've never had like old tweets
resurfaced like they're just they're
they never went through a major scam
they're not controversial at all they're
just like beloved they're all these
brands want to work with them like and
then to hear that like you know and i
think it was um bonnie said it you know
the hate stresses you out when you're
working with brands because you don't
want the brands to see it and be like
maybe we shouldn't work with this person
and it's like but the hate is so
unfounded and it's like
it's so crazy like you think you're
doing something wrong when like you
didn't
yeah yeah so they like stress out about
that they stress out about everything
and also like the level of like social
anxiety that they have even like the the
friends that they're with the people
that they're friends with like tick-tock
is like yeah i don't leave my house like
you're 16-year-old girls that's not
normal no it's so it's so sad and like
when a bonnie was like i can't when i go
to a restaurant we try like both of us
are too like nervous to order to order
like
yeah no like and then when they were
talking about noah back who i literally
adore they were like he's just
neurotypical like he doesn't have any of
these issues and i'm like you know what
you're right like there's such a
difference in in the way he speaks on
the show like versus dixie and dixie
gets a lot of [ __ ] cause she's like
monotone and she's like quiet but the
thing is what i learned from the show
was like you think you know these girls
like you don't know them at all yeah and
her relationship with noah was the best
part of the show i'm such a dixie fan i
followed her after the show like i feel
like she actually had a lot of growth on
the show yes from episode one to the
last episode like it's a brand new dixie
she's really blossomed she's really
blossomed and i love that for her like
and you know what they made a good point
cause like of course they get so much
[ __ ] like dixie's not a real singer and
she's like okay but if you were getting
these opportunities to like you know
sing and perform at wouldn't you
like it's so moronic but it's just crazy
because the way that i saw it not that i
thought that much about them before but
like dixie
and char like became really famous and
then she put out a song be happy and
then i was like everywhere was so
popular and i was popping and i never
realized that like her singing career
was fraught with all this hate yes yeah
i had no idea because like her songs
were so popular well that's what people
on the internet do and by the way those
girls also are really
very poignant and like they get so much
hate and those [ __ ] boys that they're
friends with like bryce hall like they
get no hate and they actually commit
crimes like bryce hall like starts
fights in restaurants and like everyone
loves him and like charlie and dixie
release a youtube video where like they
spit out a piece of food that they
didn't like and it was literally
worldwide news right i remember that so
like there is this insane double
standard and it's like crazy that these
really young girls like are able to
point it out
especially as it perceives like canceled
culture getting canceled she was like
these boys can do whatever they want and
like i do something like benign and i'm
a criminal
yeah but when i think of like bri i
don't again i don't think of them but
like bryce hall and the others whose
names i don't even know okay it's like
because they're what doing their
criminal activity and they're posting to
tick tock but like they don't have a
drink with duncan like so even though
they technically get away with more
they don't get the opportunities that
these girls get for being such great
because they're the great girls that
they are yeah you know that's true the
brace hall doesn't have a line with
hollister no and by the way they're busy
like i i know that like their work gives
them so much anxiety but like i was
really interested in like all their
calendars and like what other projects
they were working on like i knew they
had social tourists like a line of
clothing but i didn't know that it was
funded by hollister like i was just
learning a lot about their business yeah
the clothes were super cute everything
that they do they obviously have a very
like a lot of effort yeah but it was
just really surprising and i actually
think the show will be
it's not at all what i thought the show
was going to be and i think anybody who
takes the time to watch it will be
really surprised by it and of course it
makes you think twice about what you say
about anyone and also because you just
never know but i think i don't think
before the show i ever would have like
really felt badly for charlie and dixie
but like after this i'm just like
it's i think people will lay off of them
if they take the time to watch it i also
do think that was
part of the reason why they wanted to do
the show i'm sure they didn't want
another project to take on another like
invasive thing that people could judge
but i do think like i i don't think any
of it was acting like i think that like
when jason's having that breakdown
about the people her youtube video like
she gets this amazing opportunity to do
it 24 hours in a day with dixie vlog for
vogue what should she not take it
because technically like other people
might deserve it more like yeah but she
and she by the way she completely
acknowledged that but i don't think she
was expecting the comments to be like
you're ugly like you're musty
and it
no way did i think that was acting like
at all
but i do think part of the reason they
released the show is like in the hopes
that people would just [ __ ] off a little
bit yes [ __ ] off for them but also in
general like when
and it makes me sad to just to think
about like all the kids out there famous
or not famous like that live like this
in their phones like the other people's
comments in their high school like other
people other kids experience it on like
a micro level and like the kids are not
okay no every time i watch something
that like
highlights like the gen z culture and
like even if it's like award shows like
the kids are not okay and what are we
doing to help these kids no the kids are
not okay that was like the social
dilemma too like if you yes we were like
16 years old like maybe a little younger
like fully formed pretty much
when we started like getting inundated
with social media and like
being attached to our phones but like
these kids are attached to their phones
from like the age of seven like it's
crazy and it's not normal and like i
feel like charlie and dixie are like a
byproduct of that like on a huge level
right plus the kids are not okay like
the phones are causing like incredible
mental health issues and then also for
the last two years they're not allowed
to leave their house yeah they can't go
to school when they do leave their house
they have to wear a mask they already
have like social
anxiety issues and now they they can't
like it's so
stifling the kids are are [ __ ] and
that's what i took away from the show
and i just i need to understand what
we're going to do to help these kids
because this is untenable yeah i agree
and i think
it was just shocking yeah
but it was a good show it was a good
show it's just so interesting like their
life now they also didn't really talk
about addison i was like curious i know
and also but i also think like i wonder
i would love to hear how addison like
addison had the exact same experience as
charlie pretty much she's just a little
older i can't remember i was talking to
you or margot about this but i had a
this is just a theory and i don't think
that
it's it
it might be true but like the way that i
perceive the whole addison of it all is
like the way addison grew up and the way
charlie and dixie grew up is actually
really different like charlie and dixie
grew up in
like upper middle class of connecticut
and addison and her mom have spoken
about like on their podcast i like they
grew up just differently like much
poorer and i think that like
of course the shift from charlie's
former life to her current life is so
different but i think it's
so much more different for addison that
like you know this is her new life and
she's just kind of swallowing the hard
parts and
really focusing on the fact like she is
able to support her entire family they
all moved out to la like they all have
their own jobs they're all making money
from this like i think that
her mentality is just different because
of that that's just the way that i
perceive it i have no idea if that's
true and also probably because of her
age oh that helps for sure even because
even though years between charlie and
addison are like probably the most how
old is
i think addison's 21 no
i'm pretty sure she is
legal drinking age 20 20. okay four
years
i think she was born in 2000 that's so
crazy she's actually turning 21 in like
a month oh that's exciting
i think those years make a big
difference
of course but i would love to get a
similar show from addison and also like
it is really interesting to see
the career choices that they all make
but i do think like the girls are so
unhappy like is this worth it i would
say no i would say no to go home to
connecticut she could be in the studio
with gemma and she could still do social
tourists she could still do brands on
tick tock totally
it doesn't have to be this immersive
envelope in l.a especially with kovid
like there's just like you're gonna
travel less and stuff but connecticut is
close to new york no i feel like is it
worth it for charlie no i feel like
dixie has a better like grasp on things
i i don't think it's worth it for
charlie she's a better craft but it's
not great but if since he was the only
one on the show i would still be like
it's not worth it yeah i just feel like
dixie like finds actual joy in her music
and like and that part of her career
excites her and i don't know if there's
anything about charlie's career that
makes her excited yeah and that's why in
the beginning i was so glad that she was
still doing dance and i know they even
want to do it i know because and i
understood why at the end of the day
like it just became one more thing that
she needed to do and it was like she'd
rather have free time
but i feel like that's really like what
grounded her
in like her old life and then to take
that away it's just like she's just out
in la untethered untethered
it was it was a a real shock the whole
show yeah
i just
just you you think you know people and
you think like you see something like i
want that like i want to be the most
famous tick tocker
it ain't it like it's not it
yeah and they have no like
you know
they talk so badly about themselves and
they're just like i don't deserve this
like listen if it was that easy to just
dance on tick tock and be the most
famous girl in the world everyone would
do it so many there would be so many
more charlie demilios and there's not
there's something special about you
there's something that people really
like about you like
allow yourself to be proud of that
totally and even with dixie when she was
like people just say i got fame like i'm
just famous because charlie's famous and
i'm like okay that's cool but like that
there's no self-esteem that's not true
because so many people are famous so
many people have siblings siblings so
many people have even thirsty siblings
and they're not dixie grande and she
he's not dixie dude no that's so true so
like again dixie there is something
about you that people really like i
agree and you it's okay to be proud of
that no honestly i watched a show by
takeaway was like oh i want to be
friends with dixie like i really was
just funny liking she's and she got more
comfortable as the show went on but
you're right like they have no
self-esteem yeah and it's just so sad
because they're they've not accomplished
nothing and they really look at
themselves like i don't deserve to be
here
and you yes you can always say there's
someone who deserves it more there's
someone more talented but like
you can also
there's proof in the pudding no but you
can also like
say nice things about yourself too but
it doesn't take away from everyone who's
done more the doctors and nurses and
time one hundred do you think charlie
was right about that charlie you
inspired people this year you did yeah
the whole world was dancing on tick tock
yeah watching your videos no like
changing the zeitgeist
and that's just the truth that's facts
yeah
you know no totally
so it just it made me sad it made me
really sad like [ __ ] depressing yeah
yeah
just you really never gonna know what's
going on behind closed doors and this is
like the the real message here is like
what you see on social media i know
everyone says it like this is like an
actual adaptation of what you see on
social media versus screaming crying in
your bedroom like just please keep that
in mind like when you're scrolling
social media and everyone's life looks
so fabulous like they crying their rooms
too and they have body image issues like
it's just this was like an actual
personification of like what you see
verse reality no and it was probably the
most drastic
one i've i've seen
what's so crazy is like the hate they
get is like actually coming from 11 year
olds like the kids are are not well no
they're seriously not
um any other thoughts on the dblio show
i think i'm good if something else comes
to me i'll bring it up i started
watching only murders in the building
which is a hulu show that i've been
hearing a lot about that like i was so
confused about cause i'm like why are
steve martin martin short like a iconic
comedy duo for the last 50 years doing a
show with selena gomez but i watched it
because i read somewhere that like some
you know
magazine
rated it like the best show ever
released on hulu and i was like oh my
god
um and ben loves steve martin and martin
shorten so we watch it together and i
have to say i was
so pleasantly surprised first of all the
concept of the joke i just tell you what
it is
yeah there's a murder in the building
yeah there's a murder in the building
but like there's three like random
people in the building who don't know
each other who are obsessed with true
crime podcasts that they start their own
podcast to solve this crime in the
building like and it turns out there's
so much more going on in the building
than we had originally thought
and selena gomez plays this like
mysterious like weird like you know like
teenager or whatever
and i'm very hard on selena gomez mostly
because i think a lot of times you know
when she comes out singing like she's
constantly disappointing us and i'm just
like how is this the most followed
person just remember the demilio show
totally you're so right but what i was
gonna say it's like we forget like what
do you think of selena gomez i think of
singer she's really like not like she is
a
born and bred actor yes she got famous
on wizards of waverly place she did a
lot of acting before she said they made
her sing they made her sing which i
really maybe i don't know i just feel
like it's not her true passion i feel
like makeup and acting are her true
passion and she's stellar in both rare
beauty is a
killer brand and literally jackie i was
shook because you know like when someone
that famous is in a tv show and they're
not like a great actor it's like you're
just distracted by their obviousness you
know like they're not blending into the
show as like a real member of the person
who lives in the building she's
excellent like i have to say i was
really surprised like she is such a good
actress and she is a big role like main
character and i was just really
surprised like and totally off like what
i thought it was gonna be i love the
show there's only three episodes now
they're releasing them i think weekly
which is
so annoying that's annoying that's like
nine perfect strangers i'm just waiting
but it's a really good show i feel like
they really
there's such a good vibe about it like
it's so new york
and it's like so like pre-pandemic new
york it's just like they live on the
upper west side and just like really
makes you like love new york it's really
it's an amazing show steve martin is so
funny and martin short is so funny i
highly recommend like i just did not
think that's what my takeaway from the
show was gonna be but me and ben were
loving it okay so good i'm gonna watch
it but i do want to wait same with
impeachment it premiered last night it
did yeah i recorded it okay i thought
we're living in the digital age what is
with all these shows dropping weekly fx
is like it's still channeled by oh it's
on cable yeah [ __ ] that's so annoying
because i really want to watch it yeah
well i record it so you can come through
but i want to watch it all together yeah
okay and then i watched clickbait which
like everyone is obsessed with it's
starring adrian grenier it's a netflix
show and it's like a murder mystery and
like the whole time it was so good
yeah and you liked it no i know but he's
also not really in it that much okay
cool but he like i don't want to spoil
it but he's just like not in it um
it's really good except like the main
character is like
the sister of the person who gets
murdered and her name is pia i've never
heard of this actress before and she's
the most distracting haircut you could
ever imagine it's a bright yellow bob
with bangs straight so she literally
looks like
edna mode but blonde it's so distracting
and she's like the worst character and
she honestly at times made the show
unwatchable but there's a major twist at
the end like you never saw coming and
it's really good okay i thought
clickbait was like a documentary i
thought it was gonna be like a show
about teenagers you
know on tick tock like click bait no
that's demilio no literally but it's
totally not what i thought and i very
much enjoyed it yeah
then i watched netflix did a documentary
on caitlyn jenner
more about
caitlyn's time at the olympics and not
her transition they did focus on the
transition obviously but i feel like
we've seen so many
and heard so much from caitlyn about her
transition but i never really like knew
that much about her time at the olympics
right because you weren't alive right or
like how she even got to the olympics or
her first wife like it was really
interesting now
the
parts of it i did feel like were
revision is history because like after
the olympics
caitlin and his wife
and her wife um like things don't work
out whatever and they go through
caitlyn's many marriages and they
totally skipped over linda thompson like
and brody and uh brandon that's so weird
it was so weird it just went straight to
chris why i don't know that's really
weird and then like i feel like the
documentary really missed like of course
this like life with chris was amazing
but chris also reinvented the [ __ ] out
of caitlyn like caitlyn was becoming
irrelevant like caleb was on wheaties
and you know
they when you win the decathlon it's
like you're uh
the best athlete in the world like
that's what they call you and caitlin
went on this tour and these events but
then like people moved on with their
lives and forgot about caitlyn jenner
but chris was like integral in caitlyn's
business in reinventing caitlyn going on
motivational speaking tours right did
not mention any of that
yeah
none of it but then at this point
they're more so talking about caitlyn's
transition
and how
um
bert who i believe is
from caitlyn's first marriage knew in
the sixth grade
like caitlyn had tried so many times to
come out so like for us it was so
shocking when it happened but like for
people around caitlyn it was
like finally like they had known for
years yeah and i feel like
linda thompson i feel like something
must have happened with linda thompson
because like why would they cut her out
that is really weird especially because
did they have people
participating i feel like she would have
participated yes they had um
caitlyn's first wife who like when you
hear the story it's like so cute like
caitlyn went to graceland college
because she got like some random
scholarship like for football or
whatever
tore her knee and like couldn't really
compete in anything other than the
decathlon and became obsessed with the
decathlon met this girl and they just
wrote it out together for like eight
years caitlyn went to two olympics first
time like irrelevant like had the best
time second time like met someone at the
first olympics from the ussr at the time
and was like i'm going to beat you and
became obsessed with this russian
olympian like i'm going to beat this
russian olympian and eventually caitlyn
didn't beat this fresh olympian and her
wife was just there the whole time and
it was like in another life like they
would have been like the cutest like
married forever but they had burped and
then obviously
after achieving this like major major
thing
caitlyn was still so unhappy and that
and that like became like a thing in
their marriage right so i really felt
like it was a good documentary because
like now caitlyn is like so messy and
like out of control but
and myself included people forget like
what she did yeah it's like it was it
was really good actually i enjoyed it
but you have to go into it knowing like
some of it is definitely not like 100 i
want to check it out i um want to talk
about cinderella oh yes because i
watched it i was so excited i watched it
on friday night i think and i'm going to
start with the positives because i have
a lot of really strong positives and a
lot of really strong negatives and my
net though is negative of course sorry
to say positive camila cabello was
amazing wow she was such a good actress
she's obviously an amazing singer she
was a star she didn't distract i wasn't
like camilla cabello but i was also like
camilla yeah
she was so good she did a great job and
she's gorgeous like probably just a
vision to watch a vision and the
wardrobe was actually really good
because as we know she's a dressmaker
and she loves her dresses even though
like she's a boss babe i wasn't crazy
about like her
ball gown dress but still it wasn't that
bad um billy porter also did an amazing
job it's crazy how fairy godmother is
only in like five seasons yeah one scene
literal one scene getting her ready for
the ball so but that was a um a pretty
fun scene
so that was good i thought minnie driver
did an excellent job she played them the
queen
she was the mother of the prince that's
funny and just she really um
stood out to me and pierce brosnan
played the king and he's you know so
piercy so king king-ish yeah but um
didn't i just minnie driver stood out to
me idina menzel played stepmother
and it was it was all over the place
then for the sisters i didn't know one
of them but the other one was the girl
who played tracy turnblad and hairspray
hairspray live the most recent one oh
not nikki blonsky not nikki blonsky
and um so i thought that was a fun fact
it was glad to see her working you love
like when the live musicals just like
pop up in everyday life
i do thank you
now for the negatives so first of all
this movie was like not authorized in
any way so that's what you told me and
that's what i want to talk about because
cinderella is a disney story this movie
was not authorized in any way by disney
and you can tell because none of the
songs from any version of cinderella are
in this movie
they
it's all contemporary songs kay cannon
who's pitch perfect is the director of
this so it's very pitch perfecty they're
all singing there's medleys there's
mashups
and i just thought it was really stupid
and also the song choices like
stepmother singing material girl i
personally
i personally was good on that
yeah um the one original song a million
dreams or whatever i loved gonna wake up
and see
and
i wish there was more of that because i
thought that those moments were really
special but like it it the all the like
the singing mashups and like the dancing
and the extras it really had the same
quality to me as descendants like
just like the villagers dancing in the
village it was like on the one hand the
production value was so high you could
tell they had like unlimited budget and
then on the other hand when it came to
like
scenes in the town and stuff it was
disney channel made for tv well like
honestly
i really wasn't planning on watching it
but and i hadn't thought of it until you
brought it up like
why a disney remake is on amazon prime
like it makes no sense if there was a
new cinderella it would be on disney
plus yeah so
why did they do like a generic brand
cinderella on amazon prime
beats me
another thought that i had
the cinderella story the story of
cinderella i'm sorry to this woman is
not worth telling over and over and over
again by the way i thought that that
when we rewatched um
cinderella with whitney houston it was
like you're distracted by whitney
houston and brandy and like the music
but it's really like a boring story and
really short it's boring it's depressing
the most of the movie is like bad times
for cinderella and like harding you're
just like [ __ ] fine during the glass
slipper like it's like really
frustrating and so and also like i'm
always surprised by the fact like i love
the high budget like live action remakes
of movies and i've still never seen the
cinderella with robert madden and lily
james like i've seen bits and pieces but
like because this story is not a good
story it's not one that we should be
telling over and over and over again and
then in this cinderella they
they changed the story a little bit and
that made it worse honestly like the end
i guess i won't spoil it for you guys
but like she told me and it's morocco my
eyes are just rolling in the back of my
head like it's just so dumb they wanted
to be like so
like
new and different and like progressive
and it's just like
yeah it's an eye roll it's just they're
trying too hard
the thing is with these like disney
movies
what one of us watching wait no but i'm
just saying like with this whole thing
like disney movies are obviously like
very old school like there's a princess
who needs to be saved by the prince and
i don't know if the answer here is to
like redo this classic stories and make
like the woman a feminist maybe it's
just like make a different movie
perhaps that's just my thought because
like this stuff is cringe yeah like that
was with the beauty and the beast remake
like we were watching these special
effects no i'm saying we were watching
these special effects where like you
know emma watson was having this like
internal struggle because like she's
such a feminist and she's doing a story
about being the beast where essentially
like belle marries her abuser
stockholm syndrome so she was like
trying to you
know internalizing that struggle
agency so she like hiked belle's dress
up and it was attempt to make belle look
more industrial whatever that's fine
because they didn't really change of
course if we look too into it like is
this a good story for our children
marrying your abuser no but it's a story
like it's a movie and it's just not that
serious like
so and if you want to make a serious
movie go do that a different movie yeah
but what you're saying is like they took
the cinderella story and changed it they
changed the end yes i'm not a fan of
that
i wasn't a fan of it at all like by then
there had been so much like cringe eye
work ira worthy stuff that i was like i
was like [ __ ] turn it off like right
it was so painful and then also so james
corden is in it and he's an executive
producer i saw at the end which
explained why he gave himself the
biggest role right for a mouse for a
mouse he was a mouse who turns into a
footman and like you could just tell
footman um
carriage
got it man got it with the reins and
squeegee girl who does the both sides
carriage man and like in all other
versions of cinderella like you don't
know who played the mouse in the foot
man like it's just a mouse and then a
man with the wig and he thought that he
was hysterical he thought he was a star
of the movie like they don't stop like
the conversations among the mice like in
every scene the dialogue just ran on way
too long like you you could just tell
they thought they were the funniest
people ever in every scene and it was
like it's not funny no i mean there's
like a viral
moment going around on tick tock now
what is it um
where like billy porter um
transforms her when she screams and
she's like i look amazing and he's like
yes future queen yes like everyone's
just like cringe it really was cringy i
don't even know like the context i wanna
just like you know there were so many
cringe-worthy moments in the movie that
in watching it that wasn't even one of
those it didn't even stick out too no
because i i liked um
i liked the dynamic between cinderella
and there and they did a good job i
thought and so it's funny that that's
even like getting knocked no and like
it's really painful to watch yeah it was
just
it was not good and i had actually
really high hopes because the trailer
looked amazing the cast was amazing and
camilla just came out swinging and i was
like oh she will carry this film yeah it
was so long
they thought they were doing something
they were doing nothing i'm sorry you
didn't enjoy it yeah well you when you
tell me you were watching cinderella it
reminded me that i wanted to watch
cruella
and i know i'm like the last person to
watch corella but unbelievable film like
if you have kids or if you're just like
an adult looking for a good movie there
are no good movies out watch krill it
was incredible okay i'm going to i can't
believe you didn't see it
because you know what like i do
i know i watch all these movies like get
so excited for them and then they
[ __ ] stink no cruella was incredible
first honestly
that's that's the difference between
like disney and an amazon studios movie
like disney's cares so much about the
integrity of the storyline like it was
the it's a prequel so it's like how
corella became evil and it's literally
like the perfect prequel there's no
stone left unturned everything from the
original what you already know about
cruella makes total sense like there's
no [ __ ] it's so good and then it's
also so contemporary like
it's just it was amazing i can't wait to
watch it did you watch with theo though
i did and he was losing his mind he
wasn't triggered no he was just
even though cruella
does what she does well one day
you'll have to say you'll understand why
you'll understand no no just you'll
understand why she wants no you'll say
mass murder the pups you'll see okay yes
you will 100 understand why oh okay okay
also then the last thing is i started
nine perfect strangers and i despised it
okay it was so slow and melissa mccarthy
was just being so funny and they kept
showing me like other stupid people at
the resort who like were not being funny
and i'm like if you don't bring me back
to melissa mccarthy
i want a whole show about melissa
mccarthy's character she's like a
colleen hoover hoover yes oh you read
the book right so she's just like this
no i i'm watching the show i didn't read
the book oh so she's just i want to know
more about her life like give me the the
spin-off after she leaves the retreat
like she was so funny how many episodes
did you watch literally 20 minutes of
the first one like i uh despised i do
tell you more about it i just met nicole
kidman and like
i just i'm not buying masha i'm not
buying any of this like i really didn't
like it i kind of agree with you like
i'm just looking for [ __ ] to watch so
i'm not going to complain with you
things that are decent yeah
but it's so dragged out again they just
these people constantly think they're
doing something yeah that's so true
that's like literally the and they can't
the theme of hollywood they can't stop
themselves no they can't see themselves
you know they can't like shorten
anything they can't cut anything like
it's painful it is i don't think i'm
gonna finish it like i i don't even know
i wasn't compelled at all life's too
short to watch shows that don't
especially when i have an erotic novel
waiting for me
[Laughter]
especially i started a new book
the social graces by renee rosen oh i've
read it
what did you think so good what was your
favorite part probably when she graced
very socially i mean that happens
constantly in the book so which instance
oh when um
when she's gracing and it's like
super social huh i haven't gotten there
yet or sometimes you know what norma's
actually my favorite part of the book
when she's socializing
so gracefully
i must have not gotten there no it's at
the end okay i'll let you know
what's it about it's about it's like
early it's late um
19th century early 20th century new york
which is just like my vibe
and
they mentioned street names like yes and
they're the same
yeah most yeah so weird
um
and it's about
mrs astor and alva vanderbilt it's like
a you know changing of the guards
society wow that's like
maybe you'll read about anderson cooper
i hope not
like i seriously hope not well that's
funny well enjoy your book i'm gonna go
home and read my erotic novel if that's
okay with you sounds so great i'm
actually so booked and busy today you
gotta get a glass of wine you know dim
the light
get erotic you know get over here
literally
actually no um my housekeeper's here
today so maybe i'll wait till she leaves
before i go ahead and read the erotic
novel that's a good idea it makes me
feel weird
as it should even like last night like
ben was asleep and i'm like reading an
erotic novel i just feel like i was
doing something wrong you know like i
was just trying to fall asleep and i had
this book and i was like my sister made
me read it i'm not doing anything wrong
but like been sleeping and i'm like you
know i'm like such a stereotype like
lonely housewife
i felt like i was doing something wrong
i'm dying no it was so weird like it was
so funny it just didn't feel right so
i'm just gonna wait till i'm like in a
good space no one's in my house like and
then you're gonna finish it it's good
you know you need to finish it okay and
everyone please read the book so we can
rate yeah we need to discuss
read the book uh enjoy this episode
check out our patreon new episode first
of the month with a special guest
announcing a big big announcement we're
not being dramatic big tings patreon.com
morning toast thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast life stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
please and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
already have catbox all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find out
some morning chelsea five star view
about our beautiful stunning and smart
we are if you're still here in honor of
the erotic novel we're all currently
reading drop an emoji of the book
okay and then an eggplant book and like
yep on our most recent instagram to let
us know that you made it to the end of
the episode we love you guys have a
great day happy hump day tomorrow
you